hello everyone this is gonna be a short
play through of SCP secret laboratory
I'm gonna try
play with people it's a predominantly
multiplayer game so if I don't end up
playing with people don't let this
reflect the end game
also this isn't beta as well so there's
probably gonna be a lot of things added
to this in the past and the future in
the future yeah so I'm gonna try and
connect your to see if anybody else is
playing it's about 2 p.m. the minute in
the K so I guess we'll see hopefully
somebody I'll connect if not I'll just
try and do a local game and see if
anybody else he's connected to my game
yeah okay no
not even another person just me just
checking to see if it crashing oh yeah
I'll just going I'll just go in that
make a local game
pretty cool man you though I guess what
do you expect from the Unity engine is
just a fantastic looking engine
yeah just for start this you are Class D
personnel escape from facility cooperate
with chaos insurgency avoid other teams
I guess the other teams that they're
talking about are other players that
would be connecting to the server
hopefully we'll get a few people
connected that will be that would be
nice just to see what this game actually
has to offer because as I said before
people don't be judging this game based
on what I'm doing right now because I
don't think it's fair unless you have
loads of people and it cuz it is it is a
multiplayer game I'll be interesting to
see if there are actually scps floating
the boat though you can actually
interact with you could jump though
instead of blink yeah so makes it feel
feel different straight away Oh key card
cool
scientists key card not very high level
but what do you expect at the very start
of the game
looks really good though right I mean I
suppose it's a bit redundant because
anything with the unity engine has more
of a chance of looking better those move
oh here we go 1 7 3 anybody up there
oh there's there's nobody here okay it's
not a sign that he is breached
containment or is this a sign that the 1
7 3 is now there at all we will find out
sooner or later I'm gonna leave open all
the doors I might have to make like a
mental checkpoint to stop myself from
being I'm so used to doing it with
different from what I have played
infinity Ronin in this game though you
don't have a stamina meter which I guess
makes exploring easier for me still
haven't got anybody connected which is
ischium okay what can you do
toilets always ominous and horror games
excuse me nope
can I get into any of these games oh my
excuse me this is all's but I have to
add it I do my vocal recordings me clear
my through constantly still have a
little bit of a cold apologies
nope can't get into any of these
cubicles oh well we've all 914 suite
that means I can put this this card in
here right cuz I look I know a lot of
people said to me whenever I was playing
containment breach that I should put
security cards in here there's there's a
chance that it will turn it into a like
a maximum level security card like a
like an administrator drop it in the
booth this time there you go okay I
guess I'm very fine is that's the only
option really
why would you do anything else alright
let's see what happens
I've actually you have to find 914 and
in the the original container look we
see looks that's exactly the same okay
I'll put it in again it's like because I
remember people saying and the original
containment breach it has a chance to
completely destroy the card or give you
something really good
weird maybe it's just different rules of
this game if it just if it gives me the
same thing again I'm just not gonna
bother probably a waste this time oh
cool
that worked this time administration
Tier one its thought better it's blue is
blue batter
I always thought blue is like the
highest one but hardly not cuz there's a
lot of red text there sure the
administration's better than scientists
right some red phones there
I think that's heavy containment right
one I remember anything
three seven two either my card worked or
this just didn't have it was not a gun
just press an e at everything it is a go
yes m1911 whoo yeehaw
doesn't seem to be any ammunition for it
I'd like the bottom right or anything
just in case I'm not gonna fire it
randomly in case I actually do see
something twelve No access denied dammit
this is supposed to be an administrator
card why don't you let me end access
tonight again
oh my god test administrator card is
poopy it's poop
yeah no joy yet over people connecting
although it isn't beta I don't know how
many people have the beta key so there's
a chance we might not actually just we
might not get anybody oh well at least
we can explore that getting shot up
because there's guns in this game uh
partly mm-hmm this was the original I
would be quite scared all red - that's
him not just open yeah
well the fields the same in this game as
it was in containment breach I am
completely lost pretty much 100% of the
time there we go heavy containment zone
yeah okay so well that's me into the
heavy containment zone I guess that's
good
left B I'm gonna take B to you because
why not why not okay so this is the main
happy containment area right left they
might want to go back darn again
am I gonna see 106 oh there's the Tesla
gets a running joke now I always get
killed by the Tesla kids oh well
[Music]
it's another lift hmm well the lifts up
here
ooh that's another card in there I find
another car to go and get another card
okay oh there's a card here there's
cards everywhere in the spot
senior guard okay that should let me in
the other room right hasti I can
remember my way back
you haven't picked it up already I'm
horrible with directions yeah that lets
me through cool don't do it out here
MTF come on her keycard okay now this is
good if I can get back tonight 14 with
this I might get something really good
hmm don't really fancy going in there
just yet I'm going up there I want like
the highest possible security card just
so I can get what are these they're not
showing up in my inventory I guess there
might be ammunition or something because
there's guns in this right so yeah it's
probably gonna be a munition through
something I'll just pick them all up
why not why not thing else in here nope
what are these servers like no no
suppose there would be no all their use
for the that's something
we got here 0:09
cool oh come on really
tier 4 on it's still blocked there also
be something really good in there okay I
really need to find scp-914 sorry again
yeah I'm keep on having the clamour
through
[Music]
I will not let that get beat me again
what's this
my crew head my crew hid whoo
it's a BFG oh cool I wait no is this
gonna blow
is this gonna blow up on my face now for
God's sake just after us
hmm okay that was very anticlimactic I
thought that was gonna like blow up on
my fuse I can't shoot it anymore price
of fire again I'm done
[Music]
no okay I guess all that ammunition but
it might have been for though but it
used up all of its ammunition in one
charge so that's like the super weapon
didn't like Whitney the game like The
BFG in quake or something sorry I have
no analogies for overwatch because I
don't thanks for scaring me there
let's it was kind of you oh one of us
three here
[Music]
all 1:06 whoo
is this one when the ICP start coming
out on me I hope so because I have I
have at least have a gun to defend
myself with it'll be cool it's gonna try
and shoot it but okay
moving on looks so cool this game up
I'll try this Thor data
yeah is it there's a chance it might be
different well that's floatin it's been
so long since I've read 106 is filed
[Music]
well that's tonight as well alright I
really need to find 9 14 again okay
tubes
screw down here then
Oh can't crunch in this game nothing
done here apart from a pile of rocks
well that was good the way we go up the
stairs again we can stop clapping on the
geometry
no ready being in here at you see him
it's a shame not even one person to see
him not even one person is connected
must be a very very private bitter I
thought I thought that was a broom felt
the smoke there for a second thought it
was just an elevator
oh well left be no go down left there
why not
that's already did I come up lifting I
thought I came up left be my mind is
going
at least if I'm going dine yeah light
containment zone try my best to find 914
so hopefully I can try and get a little
bit of a banner card that will open more
doors then I have to try and find 106
again to see what's in there which is
very unlikely because when it comes to
memorizing me as is like us I just
completely blank every time
yeah we good enough okay let's drop this
one because it's the MTF commander still
I'm very fine and let's see what happens
come on big money big money
Bing oh it's black is that is that a
good thing
Oh five level key card okay this is by
your nuts the best key card in the game
yeah yeah okay so this will print this
little bit opener anything it has to if
it's a no five one right I can't
remember where one over six is
containment chamber was vomit I'm just
gonna run a and listen until I find
something no I would be a good time for
somebody to connect because then I can
just find a really high containment zone
and hide it in the room and I can't get
to it because I have the O five key card
back at the classroom it's not what I
wanted yeah well this is the place for a
cumin yeah let's see it has to be it has
to be something I'm missing what was
that
then robot bird or something now I'm
gonna keep on going back there
like in this room again it's pretty
routine so by now I I've realized that
there there is no real threatening scps
here I assume all the threats you would
encounter would be the multiplayer
aspect of it so other people would be
trying to kill you I guess like that
they have the same objectives as me like
I started off as a d-class but other
people might start off as you know 90
lakhs or researcher or something like
that may each have different missions so
my mission as a d-class is to cooperate
with the chaos insurgency where as
scientists might have another objective
right I assume that's how it goes I
think that work so we're in the heavy
containment zone whoa no sex is
definitely here I just need to find her
cores room is I've been postures so many
times I got my original keycard beam in
here oh cool so I'll definitely be able
to get in here now
sweet be careful just in case anything
is gonna know it's just just dollars
lonesome I open this get oh wait no as a
control room up here no control room
that does nothin
can't open this kid now am I missing
something
hmm I don't know I don't know doesn't
seem to be anything I can press or
interact with so I guess I'll just move
on
suppose it makes sense no way all the
servers were here because
79s so close I feel like I've got this
oh five Cardin I'm just walking about
with a good one Hey look I have a cool
thing can't do anything with it though
gonna end this lift see what's done here
because it's not labeled it's not
labeled left so might be something a
[Music]
little more a coup weird another gun
that comes epsilon11 standard rifle oh
cool where's this he Lou night cool
weapon design though I like it I'm down
here down here even though I can't see
oh it was a door stop chirping noise
again is this a containment chamber or
something
this something ah make it oh well at
least I'm protective and kiss somebody
comes in and probably not going to I
keep on saying this but the road may not
go up again yeah as well at school Peter
because I okay oh that didn't make me
put my pants
alright this is close to the end right
because this is like close to the roof
part I've never done it but I've seen
other people play it don't pick any
level
[Music]
just get a compress any years
oh yeah so this is the roof area right
so does this mean does this mean I've
completed it no it is you have to find
the it's like a tall with like chaos
insurgency guys towards the end
oh is this it
it's probably back does it start again I
guess I'll try and go down there and see
what's under there stairs I think yeah
yeah there was alpha warhead control mmm
okay oh okay well I don't know what I
was expecting
that water will have whatever I press
that me it
oh well nobody's connected anyway that's
a fitting end of this episode Morgan on
his own decides to blow himself up I
guess I'll just run away left does it
get can I get outside of the compound
let's game over see if my cell phone get
blown up nope
it was a trendy music them
this is like the greenhouse of the SCP
funding
you escaped as the class D and entered
in spectator mode er a spectator you
will be respawns don't respawn me that's
about to blow up dammit
so as this is gonna there you go
that seemed to result in no structural
damage to the foundation at all it just
messed with their cameras OE but okay I
guess that's it
am I going to respawn
you
no doesn't look like it oh wait that
sounded like mechanical noise no okay
then well we'll just leave it at that
um I'm probably not gonna play this
again again until I can sort out some
kind of person to play it with so thanks
for watching me fumble my way around at
least we find the no five key cards
that's the positive that I'm gonna be
taking away from this thanks for
watching I'll see y'all next time expect
video soon bye
you